Bác biểu kinh loạn hội nghị, thu tính lấy mình hương bánh xã thời gian qua,
các bạn hú cột truyền nghiệp vôm xuất nghiệp nhật nhật và xuất nghiệp của bốn đồ tương nước ngoài,
điều có bước phát triển tích cửc, tuy nhiên để đặt một tiêu tăng trường kinh kế hạ con số,
cạnh tạo những đột phá mạnh mẽ hơn.
Nhất là phật huy vai trò dẫn sát của các xuất nghiệp nè hợp đồ tạo,
xuất nghiệp công nghệ cao trong đồn mới sáng tạo, chuẩn đổi số và chuẩn đổi xanh.
Thù tính nhấn mạnh, tính thần xuyên xuất của hội nghị là chuyển mạnh tính nhận dẹn thảo gửa khó khăn,
sáng quan thiện nền tàn kiến tạo phát triển, tư rối thoại sáng hành động quyết liệt,
từ căng kếc sáng kết quả của thế có địa chỉ có thời hàn hướng tới mục tiêu tăng trường nhanh và biến bấm.
Đồng thời yêu cầu các bộ ngành địa phương hành động với tính thần khần trường quyết liệt hiệu quả không nè chẳng không đồn đầy.
Để hiện thức khoámu tiêu này, thù tính yêu cầu tiếp tục hành thiện thế chế,
các các thức chất tụi thực hành trính, sả sóa toàn dẹn các quy định liên quan đến đầu tư đất đại quy hoạch xây dựng môi trường
đấu thảo thủy hải quan và kiểm tra chuyên hành. Chù đồng sự liên ai những vướng mắt thuộc thầm quyền
chấn rất tình trạm quy định trong tráo các hiểu khắc nhau và nè chẳng chắc nhập.
Bình kệ nó chính phủ sẽ tiếp tục khơi thông các mừng lực về vốn đất đại và đầu tư.
Để nhé ngán thủy hành thoán thành quyết phản vốn đầu tư công bảo đầm sông tiền cho sản xuất kinh ruang.
Đúng thời các sản chỉ vì loa thức chế vì tuần thủ và đẩy mạnh chuyển đổi số trong hoạt động của li nhà nước.
Thủ tưởng công yêu cầu các buộc ngành địa phương tắc trong phát triển một nhân lực chất lượng cao
các vấn với dụ cầu xuất nhập. Thúc đại liên kết giữa cơ sở đồng tạo về nghiên cứu và xuất nhập.
Hoàn thành đúng tiến độ kế hoạch hành động một trang này sử lý các biển ngán về chuyển đổi số trong hệ thông chính trị.
Đối với cộng đồng xuất nhập. Thủ tấn đề nghị xuất nhập nhất nước tiếp tục giữa vài tròn giận giác trong các liên tục chính lật
xuất nhập đường nhận phát triển và tròn lượng quân trọng của nên tinh tế.
xuất nhập FBI tăng cường chuyển sốc công nghệ nào tạo nhân lực và nâng cao tỷ lệ nội điệu quá.
Đông thời các buộc ngành sớm xây dựng kơ chế liên kết thực chất giữa bà của vực xuất nhập nhập hình thành trộy xả trị.
Mình cao năng lực cạnh tranh và tạo lượng lực mới cho tăng trường tinh tế đất nước.